françois hollande l'a annoncé l'état de
catastrophe naturelle sera reconnue dès
mercredi pour enclencher le processus
d'indemnisation les sinistrés auront dix
jours pour effectuer une déclaration de
sinistre
les particuliers ont beaucoup souffert
mais les commerçants aussi ce reportage
à corbeil essonnes de johanna jacquot
albrecht est de 10 bassompierre à
corbeil essonnes la scène continue de
monter et les commerçants s'inquiètent
jusqu'ici le voile et là il ya un maître
un médecin quand même pas si ça veut
dire si ça s'arrête pas vite
ben ça varie le restaurant afin de
restaurer les futures mais le restaurant
reste ouvert tant qu'il le pourra le
gérant veut continuer à travailler
on est inondé on a tous un banc des
frigos des bouteilles la marchandise on
a tout perdu
voilà aux alentours du fleuve
l'eau s'infiltre partout ce bureau tabac
a dû fermer il ne peut plus rien vendre
toute la marchandise est perdu il faut
la faire repartir chaque fournisseur est
recommandée ou du film du produit offre
dans d'autres entreprises
on essaye encore de lutter contre la
montée des eaux
on est en train d'essayer de sauver un
bon contrôle de freinage mais sa voix la
peau des fesses
et puis puis on a tout les atouts
surélevé on fait au mieux pour limiter
les dégâts
une machine à plus de 40000 euros sans
compter le coût de la fermeture forcée
du garage et une perte d'activité et
l'assurance quand aurait lieu que les
experts parce qu'ils évaluent n'espérant
pont starship seront pas inonder qu'on
pourra retrouver toutes les factures et
puis voilà quoi ici comme dans tout le
département
difficile d'évaluer le montant des
dommages tant que les eaux ne se seront
pas retirés
[Musique]